ich bin der leiter des logistikzentrums
hier in portimao navy veteran über 20
jahre bei der navy und wenn dann ende
2016 zu haben so hier in baltimore seit
märz 2017
zuerst muss ich sagen das ist eine große
verantwortung und eine erfahrung die
einen demütig werden lässt 3000
mitarbeiter zu haben die sich auf dich
verlassen wir das richtige umfeld zum
arbeiten geben muss das macht jeden tag
bin ich zur arbeit gehe spaß das ist mir
wichtig mich für das team einzusetzen
und zu sehen wie sie großartige dinge
für unsere kunden
auf die frage was er von der navy mit in
seinen jetzigen job nehmen konnte macht
die charismatische frage was ist der
hand aber in der nähe habe ich gelernt
zu organisieren und große teams zu
leiten
viel ist hier ist ganz ähnlich hier gibt
es viele angestellte wir müssen alle an
einem strang ziehen diese fähigkeiten
lassen sich überall hin übertragen egal
wohin ich glaube umso mehr hier wir
verlassen uns auf unsere mitarbeiter wir
reden viel über technik aber letzten
endes geht es darum dass unsere leute
das macht den unterschied und deswegen
wir sind einer der führenden roboter
obwohl wir erst drei jahre
ich bin mir sicher dass es einfach
freude macht zu sehen wie die roboter
die art und weise verändert mit der wir
mit unserem inventar und dem gebäude
integrieren
nicht dass wir so viele die geschäfte
aber die roboter ist möglich was uns
viel effektiver gruppe viel produktiver
zu sein und ein viel größeres
geschäftsführer produktion
amazon ist nach wie vor auch für die
deutschen online-händler die schon
relativ weit in die zylinder immer der
innovator und die anderen folgen
das kann man auch an der anzahl der
patente festmachen 1600 patente im
letzten jahr angemeldet amazon ist das
schlicht und ergreifend
innovation spa schiene es geht einfach
nur mit investitionen
wenn man die gretchenfrage im deutschen
handel stellt was investieren sie dann
ist das selbst bei großen deutschen
handelskonzern von den
gesamtinvestitionen pro jahr den anteil
der promille bereich nach wie vor nicht
natürlich haben wir genau hingucken also
amazon zahlt keine steuern misshandelt
die mitarbeiter ist das wirklich so ich
glaube immer einmal ganz fair ist ist
auch immer einfach auf amazon zu zeigen
und nicht im umkehrschluss mal zu sehen
die am doppelbesteuerungsabkommen wie
viel steuern bezahlen die dax konzerne
eigentlich in den usa
und wie sieht die logistik aber bei
anderen händlern aus und da tut sich das
wirklich wie als ich glaube das ist
alles ganz normal was verloren